you gave me an amazing tour blue origin
rocket Factory and launch complex in the
historic Cape
Canaveral uh that's where new Glenn the
the big rocket we talked about is uh
being built and will launch can you
explain what the new Glenn rocket is and
uh tell me some interesting technical
aspects of how it works sure um uh new
Glenn is a a a very large heavy lift
launch vehicle it'll take about 45
metric tons to Leo very uh very large
class um it's about half the thrust a
little more than half the thrust of the
Saturn 5 uh rocket so it's about 3.9
million pounds of thrust on
liftoff the booster has seven be4
engines the each engine generates a
little more than 550,000 lbs of
thrust the engines are fueled by liquid
natural gas liquefied natural gas LNG as
the fuel and locks as the
oxidizer the cycle is an oxr stage
combustion cycle it's a cycle that was
really pioneered by the Russians it's a
very good cycle um uh and that engine is
also going to power the first stage of
the Vulcan rocket which is the United
launch Alliance rocket um then the
second stage of new Glenn uh is powered
by two be3 U engines which is a upper
stage variant of our new Shephard liquid
hydrogen engine so the be3 U has 160,000
lbs of thrust so two of those 320,000
lounds of thrust and hydrogen is a very
good propellant for upper stages because
it has very high ISP it's not a great
propellant in my view for booster stages
because the stages then get physically
so large hydrogen
has very high ISP but liquid hydrogen is
uh very is not dense at all so to store
liquid hydrogen you know if you need to
store many thousands of pounds of liquid
hydrogen your tanks your liquid hydrogen
tank get very large so uh you really you
get more benefit from the higher ISP the
specific impulse you get more benefit
from the higher specific impulse on the
second
stage and that stage carries less
propellent so you don't get such
geometrically gigantic tanks the Delta 4
is an example of a vehicle that is all
hydrogen the booster stage is also
hydrogen and I think that it's a very
effective vehicle but it never was very
cost effective um so it's operationally
very capable but not very cost effective
so size is also costly size is costly so
it's interesting Rockets love to be big
everything works better what do you mean
by that you've told me that before it
sounds epic but was
it I mean when you look at the kind of
the physics of Rocket
engines uh and also when you look at
parasitic Mass it doesn't if you have
let's say you have an avionic system so
you have a guidance and control system
that is going to be about the same mass
and size for a giant rocket as it is
going to be for a tiny rocket and so
that's just parasitic mass that is very
consequential if you're building a very
small rocket but is Trivial if you're
building a very large rocket so you have
the parasitic Mass thing and then if you
look at for example rocket engines have
turbo pumps they have to pressurize the
fuel and the oxidizer up to a very high
pressure level in order to inject it
into the thrust chamber where it burns
and those pumps all rotating machines in
fact get more efficient as they get
larger so really tiny turbo pumps are
very challenging to manufacture and any
kind of gaps you know uh are like
between the housing for example and the
rotating impeller that pressurizes the
fuel there has to be some Gap there you
can't have those parts scraping against
one another and those gaps drive
inefficiencies and so you know if you
have a very large turbo pump those gaps
and percentage turb terms end up being
very small and so there's a bunch of
things that that you end up loving about
having a large rocket and that you end
up hating for a small rocket but there's
a giant exception to this Rule and it is
manufacturing so manufacturing large
structures is very very challenging it's
a pain in the butt and so you know it's
just you know if you have if you're
making a small rocket engine you can
move all the pieces by hand you can
assemble it on a table one person can do
it um you know you don't need cranes and
heavy lift operations and tooling and so
on and so on when you start building big
objects infrastructure civil
infrastructure just like the Launchpad
and the you know all this we we went and
visited I took you to the launch pad and
you can see it's so Monumental yeah it
is um and so just these things become
major uh undertakings both from an
engineering point of view but also from
a construction and cost point of view
and even the uh the foundation of the
Launchpad I mean this is Florida like
isn't it like swamp land like how deep
you have to go you have to at Cape
Canaveral yeah um in fact in most ocean
you know most launch pads are are on
beaches somewhere on the oceans side
because you want to launch over water
for safety reasons um the uh yes you
have to drive pilings you know dozens
and dozens and dozens of pilings you
know 50 100 150 ft deep deep to get
enough structural Integrity for these
very large you know it's it's uh yes
these turned into major civil
engineering projects I just have to say
everything about that factory is pretty
badass you said tooling the bigger it
gets the more the more epic it is it
does make it epic it's fun to look at
it's extraordinary it's humbling also
cuz your humans are so small compared to
it we are building these enormous
machines that are harnessing enormous
amounts of uh IAL uh Power um you know
in very very compact packages it's truly
extraordinary but then there's all the
different components uh and you you know
the materials involved is there
something interesting that's you can
describe about the
materials uh that comprise the rocket so
it has to be as light as possible I
guess whilst withstanding the heat into
the harsh conditions yeah I play a
little kind of game sometimes with other
rocket people that I run into where say
what are the things that would Amaze the
1960s Engineers like what what's change
because yeah surprisingly some of Rocket
tre's Greatest Hits have not changed
they are still they would recognize
immediately a lot of what we do today
and it's exactly what they pioneered
back in the 60s but a few things have
changed um uh you know the use of carbon
composits is is very different today um
you know we can build very sophisticated
you saw our carbon tape laying machine
that builds the giant fairings and we
can build these incredibly light very
stiff fairing structures out of carbon
composite material that they could not
have dreamed of I mean the the
efficiency the structural efficiency of
that material is so high compared to any
you know metallic material you might use
or anything else so that's one um uh
aluminum lithium and the ability to
friction stir weld aluminum lithium do
you remember the friction s welding that
I showed you this this is a a remarkable
technology it was invented decades ago
but has become very practical over just
the last couple of decades and instead
of using heat to weld two pieces of
metal together it literally stirs the
two pieces there's a a pin that rotates
at a certain rate and you put that pin
between the two plates of metal that you
want to weld together and then you move
it at a at a very precise speed um and
instead of heating the material it Heats
it a little bit because of friction but
not very much you can literally
immediately after welding with stir
friction welding you can touch the
material and it's just barely warm um
it's it literally stirs the molecules
together it's quite extraordinary
relatively low temperature and I guess
high temperature is what makes them the
the that's the we that makes it a weak
point exactly so in with traditional
with traditional welding techniques you
may have whatever the underlying
strength characteristics of the material
are you end up with weak regions where
you weld and with friction stir welding
the welds are just as strong as the bulk
material so it really allows you and so
cuz when you're you know let's say
you're building a tank that you're going
to pressurize you know a large you know
liquid natural gas tank for our for our
booster stage for example you know if
you are dwelling that with traditional
methods you have to size those weld
lands the thickness of those pieces with
that knockdown for whatever damage
you're doing with the Weld and that's
going to add a lot of weight to that
tank I mean even just uh looking at the
fairings the result of that the the
complex shape that it takes and yeah and
like what it's supposed to do is is kind
of incredible cuz so people don't know
it's on top of the Rockets it's going to
fall apart that's its task but it has to
stay strong sometimes yes and then uh
disappear when it needs to that's right
which is a very difficult task yes when
you need something that needs to have
100% Integrity until it needs to have 0%
Integrity it needs to stay attached
until it's ready to go away and then
when it goes away it has to go away
completely you use explosive charges for
that and so it's a very robust way of of
separating structure uh when you need to
exploding yeah little little tiny bits
of explosive material um and uh it just
it'll sever the whole connection so if
you want to go from 100% structural
Integrity To Zero as fast as possible is
explosives use
explosives the entirety of this thing is
so badass okay so back to the two stages
so the the first stage is reusable yeah
second stage is Expendable second stage
is liquid hydrogen liquid oxygen so we
get take advantage of the higher
specific impulse um the uh the first
stage uh lands down range on a landing
platform in the ocean um comes back for
maintenance and get ready to do the next
mission um I mean there's a million
questions but also is there a a path
towards reusability for the second stage
there is and we know how to do that um
right now I we're going to work on
manufacturing that second stage to make
it as inexpensive as possible sort of
two paths for a second stage make it
reusable um uh or work really hard to
make it inexpensive so you can afford to
expend it and th that trade is actually
not obvious which one is better even in
terms of cost even like time even terms
of and I'm talking about cost is it you
know space like getting into orbit is a
solved problem we solved it back in you
know the 50s and 60s you're making it
sound e the only thing that the only
interesting problem is dramatically
reducing the cost of access to
orbit which is if you can do that you
open up a bunch of
new uh you know Endeavors that lots of
startup companies everybody else can do
so that's we really that's our one of
our missions is to you know be part of
this industry and lower the cost to
orbit so that there can be you know a
kind of a Renaissance a golden age of
people doing all kinds of interesting
things in space I like how you said uh
getting to orbit is a solved problem
it's just the only interesting thing is
reducing the you know you can describe
every single problem facing human
civilization that way the physicist
would say everything is a solved problem
we've solved everything the rest is just
uh with Rutherford said that it's just
stamp collecting just the detail some of
the greatest Innovations and inventions
and you know Brilliance is uh in that
cost reduction stage right and you
you've had a long career of cost
reduction for sure and if you know when
you what does cost reduction really mean
it means inventing a better way yeah
exactly right and when you invent a
better way you make the whole world
richer so you know whatever it was I
don't know how many thousands of years
ago somebody invented the plow mhm and
when they invented the plow they made
the whole World richer because they made
farming less
expensive um and so it it is a big deal
to to invent better ways that's how the
world gets
richer so uh what are some of the the
biggest challenges on the manufacturing
side and the engineering side that
you're
facing in uh working to get uh to the
first launch of new Glenn the first
launch is one thing we and we'll do that
in 2024 coming up in this coming year
the real thing that's the bigger
challenge is making sure that our
Factory is efficiently uh uh
manufacturing at rate so rate production
so consider if you want to launch new
Glenn you know 24 times a year you need
to manufacture a upper stage since
they're
Expendable uh every you know twice a
month you need to do one every two weeks
so you need to be you need to have all
of your manufacturing facilities and
processes and inspection techniques and
acceptance tests and everything
operating at rate and rate manufacturing
is at least as difficult
as designing the vehicle in the first
place and the same thing so every every
uh uh upper stage has two b3u engines so
those engines you know you need if
you're going to launch
this the vehicle twice a month you need
four engines a month so you need an
engine every week so you need to be that
engine needs to be being produced at
rate and and that's a um and there's all
the things that you need to do that all
the right Machine Tools all the right
fixtures uh the right people process Etc
so it's one thing to build a first
article right so that's you know we to
launch new Glenn for the first time you
need to produce a first article but
that's not the hard part the hard part
is everything that's going on behind the
scenes to build a factory that can
produce new glends at rate so the first
one is produced in a way that's enables
the production of the second third and
the fourth and fifth and sixth you could
think of the first article as kind of
pushing it it pushes all of the rate
manufacturing uh technology along you
know in other words it's kind of the uh
you know it's the test article in a way
that's testing out your your
Manufacturing Technologies the
manufacturing is the Big Challenge yes I
mean I don't want to make it sound like
any of it is easy I mean the people who
are designing the engines and all this
all of it is hard um for sure but the
but the challenge right now is driving
really hard to get to uh is to get to
rate manufacturing and to do that in an
efficient way again kind of back to our
cost point
if you get to rate Manufacturing in an
inefficient way you haven't really
solved the cost problem and maybe you're
haven't really moved the state of the
art forward all this has to be about
moving the state-of-the-art forward
there are easier easier businesses to do
I always tell people look if you are
trying to make money you know like start
a salty snack food company or something
you know you you WR that
idea like make the Lex fredman potato
chips you know this this don't don't say
it the people going to steal
it but yeah it's hard you see what I'm
saying it's like there's nothing easy
about this business and um but but it's
its own reward it's it's it's uh it's
fascinating it's worthwhile it's
meaningful and so you know I you know
not I don't want to pick on salty snack
food companies but I think it's it's
less meaningful you know at the end of
the day you're not going to you're not
going to have accomplished something
amazing yeah there's even if you do make
a lot of money out it yeah there's
something fundamentally different about
the quote unquote business of space
exploration yeah it's a sure it's a
grand project of humanity yes it's one
of Humanity's Grand challenges and
especially as you look at going to the
moon and going to Mars and building
giant O'Neal colonies and unlocking all
the things you know I won't live long
enough to see the fruits of this but the
fruits of this come from building a road
to space getting the infrastructure I
give you an analogy when I started
Amazon I didn't have to develop a
payment system it already existed it was
called the credit card I didn't have to
develop a transportation system to
deliver the packages it already existed
it was called the postal service and
Royal Mail and Deutsche Post and so on
so all this heavy lifting infrastructure
was already in place and I could stand
on its shoulders
and that's why when you look at the
internet um you know by the way another
giant piece of infrastructure that was
around in the early I'm taking you back
to like
1994 people were using dialup modems and
it was piggybacking on top of the
long-distance phone network that's how
the internet that's you know how people
were accessing servers and so on and
that again if if that hadn't existed it
would have been hundreds of billions of
capex to put that out there no startup
company could have done that and so the
problem you know you see in if you look
at the dynamism in the Internet space
over the last 20 years it's because you
know you see like two kids in a dorm
room could start an Internet company
that could be successful and do amazing
things because they didn't have to build
heavy infrastructure it was already
there and that's what I want to do I
take you know my Amazon winning
and use that to build heavy
infrastructure so the Next
Generation you know my the generation
that's my children and their children
these you know th those Generations can
then use that heavy infrastructure then
there'll be space entrepreneurs Who
start in their dorm room yeah like that
that would be a marker of success when
you can have a really valuable space
company started in a dorm room then we
know that we've built enough
infrastructure so that Ingenuity and
Imagination can really be Unleashed I
find that very exciting as they will of
course as kids do uh take all of this
hard infrastructure building for granted
of course which the entrepreneurial
Spirit that's a um an inventor's
greatest dream is that their inventions
are so successful that they are one day
taken for granted you know nobody thinks
of Amazon as an invention anymore nobody
thinks of customer reviews as an we
pioneered customer reviews but now
there're commonplace same thing with
oneclick shopping and so on but that's a
compliment that's how you know you you
you invent something that's so used so
beneficially used by so many people that
they take it for granted I don't know
about nobody I every time I use Amazon
I'm still amazed how does this work the
logistics well that proves you're a very
curious Explorer all right all right
back to Rockets
timeline you said
2024 uh as it stands now
are both the first test launch and the
launch of Escapade explorers tomorrows
still possible
in4 yeah I think so um for sure the
first launch and then we'll see if if
Escapade goes on that or not I think
that the first launch for sure and I
hope Escapade too hope well I just don't
know which Mission it's it's actually
going to be slated on yeah so we also
have other things that might go on that
first mission oh I got it but you're
optimistic that uh the launches will
still oh the first launch I'm very
optimistic that the first launch of new
Glenn will be in 2024 and I'm just not
100% certain what payload will be on
that first launch are you nervous about
it are you kidding I'm extremely nervous
about
it oh man 100% I've you know every uh
every launch I go to you know for new
Shepard for other vehicles too I'm
always nervous for these launches but
yes for sure a first launch to have no
nervousness about that would be you know
some sign of derangement I think so well
I got to visit the launch pad it's
pretty um I mean it's epic you know we
have done a tremendous amount of ground
testing a tremendous amount of uh
simulation so uh you know a lot of the
problems that we might find in Flight
have been resolved but there are some
problems you can only find in flight so
you know cross your fingers I guarantee
you you'll uh you'll have fun watching
it no matter what happens 100% when the
thing is fully assembled and comes up
yeah the the transporter erector just
the transporter erector for a rocket of
this scale is extraordinary that's an
incredible machine the vehicle uh
travels out horizontally and then kind
of you know comes up over a few hours
yeah it's a beautiful thing to watch uh
speaking of which if that makes you
nervous I don't know if you remember
but you uh were aboard a new Shepherd on
this first crude
flight uh how was that experience were
you were you terrified then you know
Strangely I wasn't you know I you ride
the
rocket I've watched other people ride in
the rocket and I'm more nervous than
when I was inside the rocket
myself um it was a difficult
conversation to have with my mother when
I told her I was going to go on the
first one and Not only was I going to go
but I was going to bring my brother too
this is a tough conversation to have
with a mom and there's a long pause told
her like both of you um and it was an
incredible experience and we were we
were laughing in inside the capsule and
you know were not
nervous um the people on the ground were
very nervous for us um uh it was
actually one of the most emotionally
powerful parts of the experience was not
happened even before the flight at 4:30
in the morning brother and I are getting
ready to go to the launch site and
Lauren is going to take us there in her
helicopter and we're getting ready to
leave and we go outside outside the
ranch house there and in West Texas
where the launch facility is and all of
our family my kids and my brother's kids
and our you know our
our parents and uh close friends are
assembled there and they're saying
goodbye to us but they're kind of saying
maybe they think they're saying goodbye
to us
forever and you know we might not have
felt that way but it was obvious from
their faces how nervous they were that
they felt that way and it was sort of
powerful because it allowed us to see it
was almost like a 10-y own memorial
service or something like you could feel
how loved you were in that moment um and
it was uh it was really amazing yeah and
I mean there's just a epic nature to it
too the asent the floating in zero
gravity I'll tell you something very
interesting zero gravity feels very
natural I don't know if it's
because we you know it's like return to
the womb he just confirmed You're an
Alien but
that's I think that's what I that's what
you just said feels so natural to be in
Zur it was really interesting and then
what people talk about the overview
effect and seeing Earth from space I had
that feeling very powerfully I think
everyone did um you see how fragile the
Earth is if you're not an
environmentalist it will make you one uh
the the great Jim level quote you know
he looked back at the Earth from space
and he said he realized you don't go to
heaven when you die you go to heaven
when you're born and it's just you know
that's the feeling that people get when
they're in space you see all this
Blackness all this nothingness and
there's one Gem of life and it's Earth
it is a gem uh what you know you're
you've talked a lot about
decision-making throughout your time
with Amazon what was that decision like
to uh to ride to be the first to ride in
your Shepherd like what just be before
you talk to your mom yeah what what like
the pros and cons like actually as one
human being as a as a leader of a
company um on all fronts like what was
that decision making like I decided that
first of all I knew the vehicle
extremely well I know the team who built
it I know the vehicle um the uh I'm very
comfortable with the like the Escape
system we put as much effort into the
Escape system on that vehicle as we put
into all the rest of the vehicle
combined it's one of the hardest pieces
of Engineering in the entire new
Shephard architecture can you actually
describe what do you mean by Escape
system what's involved we have a solid
rocket motor in the base of the crew
capsule so that if anything goes wrong
on
Ascent you know while the main rocket
engine is
firing we can ignite this solid rocket
motor in the base of the crew capsule
and escape from the booster
it's a very challenging system to build
design validate test all of these things
it is the reason that I am comfortable
letting anyone go on new Shepard so the
the the booster is safe and reliable as
we can make it but um we are harnessing
whenever you're talking about rocket
engines I don't care what rocket engine
you're talking about you are harnessing
such vast power
in such a small compact geometric space
the power density is so enormous that it
is impossible to ever be sure that
nothing will go wrong and so the only
way to um improve safety is to have an
escape system and you know and
historically Rockets human rated Rockets
have had Escape systems only the space
shuttle did not and um but Apollo had
one um the you know um all of the
previous you know Gemini Etc they all
had Escape
systems and uh we have on new sheeper
unusual Escape most Escape systems are
Towers we have a pusher Escape system so
the solid rocket motor is actually
embedded in the base of the crew capsule
and it pushes and it's reusable in the
sense that if we don't use it so if we
have a nominal Mission we land with it
the tower systems have to be ejected at
a certain point point in the mission and
so they get wasted even in a nominal
Mission and so again you know cost
really matters on these things so we
figured out how to have the Escape
system be a reusable uh in the event
that it's not used you can reuse it um
and have it be a pusher system it's a
very sophisticated thing so I knew these
things you asked me about my decision to
go and so I know the vehicle very well I
know the people who uh designed it I had
great trust in them um and in the
engineering that we did
uh and I thought to myself look if I am
not ready to go then I wouldn't want
anyone to go a tourism vehicle has to be
designed in my view to have very to be
as safe as one can make it you can't
make it perfectly safe it's
impossible but you know you have to you
people will do things people take risk
you know they climb mountains they you
know they sky dive they you know do deep
underwater scuba diving and so on people
are okay taking risk you can't eliminate
the risk but it is something because
it's a tourism vehicle you have to do
your utmost to eliminate those risks and
I felt very good about the system I
think it's one of the reasons I was so
calm inside maybe others weren't as calm
they didn't know as much about it as I
did who was in charge of engaging the
Escape system did you have it's
automated okay the Escape system is
visual is completely automated automated
is better because it can react so much
faster so yeah for for tourism Rockets
safety is a huge huge huge priority for
space exploration also but a a tin you
know a Delta less yes I mean I think for
you know if you're doing you know there
are human activities where we tolerate
more risk if you're saving somebody's
life you know um if you are you know
engaging in real exploration um these
are things where you know I personally
think you we would accept more risk in
part because you have
to